le musée est un des lieux qui donne la
plus haute idée de l'homme
cette citation de l'écrivain André
Malraux que le parfaitement à la visite
immersive qu'on vous propose aujourd'hui
le Musée de la Résistance et de la
Déportation Besançon a reversé porte le
8 septembre 2023 après 3 ans de travaux
une découvre la cruauté la violence de
l'être humain mais aussi son courage son
engagement et son pouvoir de résilience
je vous propose de me suivre à la
découverte de l'indé musée les plus
importants de France accompagné
d’étienne de learn médiateur culturel au
Musée de la Résistance et de la
Déportation de Besançon
[Musique]
on commence avec l'arrivée au pouvoir
d'Hitler en
1933 si je prends l'exemple uniquement
de cette salle elle va se diviser en
trois parties trois parties finalement
qui vont tourner autour d'un slogan
tristement célèbre le slogan du parti
nazi à l'époque a une volte à une Reich
a une fureur pour montrer si vous voulez
comment est-ce que le nazisme va je
dirais gagner en puissance et
s'infiltrer dans le quotidien des gens
montrer finalement que le nazi plus
qu'un parti politique ça va être
carrément un projet de société
dans cette première salle on entre tout
de suite dans le vif du sujet avec le
personnage principal un imposant bronze
de la tête d'Adolf Hitler est exposé à
côté d'une édition de son ouvrage Mein
Kampf c'est dans ce livre qu'il exposa
son désir d'élimination des juifs et des
Tziganes au nom d'une théorie raciale
plus loin le visage d'un autre homme
s'imposa à nous il s'agit de celui du
maréchal Philippe Pétain héros militaire
de la Première Guerre mondiale il
collabore ensuite avec l'Allemagne nazie
à travers le gouvernement de Vichy Vichy
la collaboration un ce qui est assez
indispensable parce que finalement
certaines opérations allemandes
n'auraient pu réussir sans un tel
concours des autorités françaises et
l'appui évidemment du gouvernement de de
Vichy l'occupation pèse sur le quotidien
des Français et des Français avec des
restrictions denrées mais dans l'ombre
la résistance s'organise petit à petit
l'idée c'est que au départ on commence
vraiment avec des moyens de fortune et
d'ailleurs le concept de résistance
n'existe même pas au début de
l'occupation en revanche il y a une
expression qui revient tout le temps
c'est faire quelque chose il faut faire
quelque chose ce musée met la lumière
sur plus de 500 objets et archives datés
de la résistance et confectionné en
déportation ils ont été récoltés à
travers différentes campagnes de dons
grâce à eux on entre dans le quotidien
des femmes et des hommes qui ont
traversé cet effroyable période on
découvre notamment l'histoire de Jeanne
ou deux cette jeune franc-comtoise a
tenu un journal personnel sous
l'Occupation alors qu'elle n'avait que
16 ans
plus on avance dans le musée puis la
folie nazie apparaît clairement
répression emprisonnement torture
déportation le récit serait insoutenable
s'il n'était pas axé sur les témoignages
des prisonniers pour continuer à vivre
malgré l'enfer et pour documenter leur
quotidien ils rivalisent d'ingéniosité
c'est notamment ce que fait la
résistance Germaine Tillion
je peux vous dire le nombre exact
d'interrogation parce que je les ai je
les avais comptabilisés sur une petite
imitation de Jésus-Christ que m'a donné
le
Lemonnier de la prison mais qu'il m'a
donné en janvier j'ai donc été au secret
du bois d'au au mois de janvier et à ce
moment-là j'ai eu un petit crayon gros
comme mon long comme mon pouce c'est
gros comme mon pouce avec lequel je
prenais des notes sur des petits bouts
de papier qu'on nous donnait comme
papier toilette
[Musique]
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
depuis le début les pièces commencent à
se foncer progressivement via les
nuances de gris on avait démarré dans du
gris assez clair et là petit à petit
effectivement les pièces sont en train
de se foncer
là effectivement donc on arrive dans les
pièces les plus sombres parce que là on
est vraiment au cœur si vous voulez de
la répression vous allez le voir la
pièce suivante au niveau de de
l'extermination
[Musique]
les conservateurs Byzantins réussissent
à parler d'un sujet extrêmement lourd
avec pudeur et intelligence sans tomber
ni dans le misérableisme ni dans le
manichéisme la visite de ce magnifique
musée se conclut par une très belle
salle dans laquelle la clarté revient
telle une véritable bouffée d'air c'est
celle de l'art en déportation
personnellement j'ai beaucoup aimé ce
musée et surtout la finesse avec
laquelle il a été scénographie
à votre tour maintenant de le découvrir